hey what is up everybody it's animac
here for anime outboard and Demon Slayer
season three is finally here and we're
moving from the Entertainment District
Arc into the swordsmith village Arc and
Beyond we are also meeting all of the
upper demon moons and the story is
quickly advancing towards its epic
climax so let's talk about the time skip
that occurs between the Entertainment
District Arc and the swordsmith village
Arc let's talk about what's going to
happen next and let's talk about
everything else you need to know for
Demon Slayer season three you guys know
the drill if you enjoy our Demon Slayer
content and you want us to keep it going
with many more Demon Slayer videos
please leave that like and leave a
comment right now it only takes you a
second but it helps us with that YouTube
algorithm and did you know that well
over 50 of the people who regularly
watch our videos haven't taken the time
to subscribe subscribing on YouTube is
completely free and it directly supports
the channel so do me a big favor and
subscribe Vibe right now finally this
video will contain Demon Slayer manga
spoilers I will not be spoiling the end
of The swordsmith Village Arc but I will
be talking about the setup and the
background info for this Arc so some of
that stuff will be revealed with that
said proceed with caution you have been
warned now demonstrator season 2 ended
off with our heroes defeating upper Moon
6 Doki and yutaro after that we saw that
upper Moon 3 akaza was summoned to
muzon's Infinity castle and he instantly
knew the reason for his summoning on
upper rank demon moon was just killed by
the demon Slayers and so muzon needs to
meet with all the remaining upper moons
including akaza but what is the infinity
Castle essentially this is muzon's
hidden secret base and it is located
inside a different dimension kind of
like a pocket Dimension that is separate
from the rest of the world this pocket
Dimension is designed to look like a
massive traditional Japanese Castle but
it's not an ordinary Castle because
traditional laws of physics and gravity
don't apply here it's almost like being
inside a surrealist painting of a
Japanese castle where Up Is Down and
left is right and the floor is on the
ceiling the infinity Castle was actually
created by the blood demon art of nakime
abiwa playing female demon nakima sits
at the center of this massive structure
and she manipulates the castle by
playing her biwa she can change and
shift the positions of the rooms and
walls and pillars inside of the castle
and she can even weaponize the castle
against her enemies by turning parts of
it into weapons which he can use to
attack the infinity Castle is a top
secret location which is normally used
solely by nakiman muza and it is only
rarely visited by the demon moons when
muzan decides to summon them after the
death of upper Moon 6 the first upper
moon to be defeated in 113 years muzan
decides that he must summon the
remaining upper moons in order to
discuss this troubling news and come up
with a new action plan for destroying
the demon Slayers and the hashira akaza
is the last to arrive inside the
infinity castle and the first demon he
spots is nakime herself she is not an
upper moon at this point in time but as
I said earlier she is the one who
creates and controls the castle akasa
then comes across a porcelain vase with
flowers painted on it but this is no
ordinary vase it actually talks to akaza
and then suddenly a gin-like creature
emerges from the vase and this creature
is revealed to be upper Moon 5 gyoko
gyoko is a grotesque creature with two
mouths where his eyes should be and an
eye in his mouth and on his forehead he
also has like these tiny little arms
popping out randomly from his body there
is a lot to be said about this extremely
creepy demon and I've got a whole video
on him dropping soon here on the channel
so definitely subscribe for that and
turn the notifications on after Yoko
akasa meets a short demon who looks like
a tiny old man and who just seems super
jittery and cowardly this is upper Rank
4 hunting and he is a fascinating demon
as well so I'll be dropping a whole
video on him too then we meet upper Moon
2 Doma possibly the most messed up demon
of them all and this guy is so
interesting that I've already made an
entire video about him and that link is
in the description the various upper
moons then greet each other although
akasa doesn't really greet them back
because he dislikes all of them and he
especially hates dolma when dolma
casually places his arm on akaza akaza
punches Doma in the jaw without a second
thought we are then introduced to
and soon after muzon himself arrives
muzan announces that upper rank 6
gyutaro is dead which means that the
upper Moon ranks are now incomplete
muzan believes that yutaro lost because
daki was a hindrance to him but yutaro
foolishly continued to cling to her
instead of just fighting for himself
muzan says that the upper moons are
failing in the order of who has the most
human parts remaining and he calls them
worthless they have failed to eradicate
the demon Slayers and the ubuyashiki
family and they have also failed to find
the legendary blue Spider Lily despite
searching for it for hundreds of years
muzon says that he doesn't even know why
the upper moons still exist and the
demons immediately Express their regret
for their failures and ask for
forgiveness from muza muzan hates change
because change is synonymous with
mortality that is why Utah was death and
this shift in the upper Moon rankings
disturbs him so profoundly muzon likes
that which is permanent and unchanging
and he wants to find a way to reach a
perfect unchanging state of immortality
but his life will always be at risk
until he destroys all the demon Slayers
and the ubuyashiki clan and finally
conquers the sun gyoko states that he
has some important information that will
Aid in muzon's cause and muzon instructs
him to go to a certain place with
hantangu as soon as he confirms that the
information is correct after dolma tries
to convince gyoko to let him come too he
is once again attacked by akasa for
attempting to question Lord muzon's
instructions but then akasa's left arm
is cut off in a Flash by kokucible even
though dolma doesn't mind akasa's
attacks upper Moon 1 is concerned that
akasa is going too far akas as blatant
attacks on a higher ranked demon could
create cracks in the hierarchy of the
upper moons kokushibo tells akaza that
if he doesn't like the current rankings
then he can request blood combat in
order to try and replace either Doma or
himself by killing them otherwise he
must respect the hierarchy dolma says
that it's all in good fun because akasa
has no chance of defeating the two of
them but akasa vows to kokushibod that
he is definitely going to defeat him and
upper Moon one encourages akaza to try
Kyoko and huntengu are then sent out on
their secret mission and the other upper
moons are sent on their way by nakime
this brief meeting of the upper moons
and muzon is incredibly valuable in
terms of the Insight it gives us on the
remaining upper moons including their
personalities and the type of
relationships that they have with each
other and with muzon akaza clearly
doesn't like any of the other demon
moons especially dolma and his goal is
to kill the strongest so that he can
become the strongest he doesn't care
about rules or hierarchy he just wants
to be number one kopushibo the current
number one is just the opposite he cares
deeply about order and hierarchy and he
wants to maintain it Doma is just an
absolute sociopath who pretends like the
other demons are his friends but in
reality he doesn't care for them at all
and he loves teasing and mocking them
especially akasa Kyoko is anxious to
please muzon and to prove his loyalty
and usefulness Han Tengu presents
himself as a feeble and jittery old man
but that of course is a facade and
nakume is quiet and calm and she
dutifully obeys muzon's instructions but
she's also smart enough to know that she
should stay as far away from Doma as
possible this scene also gives us
important insight into muzon's State of
Mind as I mentioned earlier he is
obsessed with mortality and ensuring
that he and the Demonic system that he
established will be permanent and
eternal on the one hand he is both
overpowered and full of himself he's an
egomaniac he thinks he is better and
stronger than everyone else but on the
other hand he is terrified of change and
death and this fear drives most of his
actions in order to truly understand
muzan's character you have to understand
this inner contradiction that he is
constantly dealing with now let's talk
about tanjiro's dream because this dream
or should I say this ancestral memory is
critical for understanding season three
and the rest of the series in this dream
we see a figure holding a baby as tea
and rice cakes are served to him this
figure looks a lot like the demon
kokushibo from behind but this is in
fact the figure that docky saw back when
she was fighting tanjiro she saw him
because during the fight muzan's own DNA
was reminded of the man that muzan fears
the most the original breath of the sun
user yorichi tsugikuni the scene in
which yorichi is holding the baby takes
place some 500 years ago During the
sengoku period of Japanese history but
if this scene is taking place 500 years
ago then why does the man who is talking
to urichi and serving him tea look
almost exactly like tanjiro but just a
slightly older version of tanjiro and
that is because this man's name is
sumioshi and he is the direct ancestor
of tanjiro kamado we are not sure if
sumioshi's last name is also kamado or
if the last name changed over the
centuries sumioshi says to yorichi that
he and his wife and child owe their very
lives to him so presumably yorichi saved
them from a demon attack but in this
moment yorichi feels depressed and he
tells sumioshi that he is a man without
value who was unable to accomplish even
one thing that he should have in this
life sumioshi refuses to accept this
kind of talk from yorichi and he vows
that even though he is just a humble
charcoal seller he will tell his
children and grandchildren about yorichi
and his great deeds sumioshi will
eventually teach his children the dance
of the fire god and they will teach
their children until this dance is
passed all the way down to tanjiro and
what is this dance of the fire god it is
none other than the original breath of
the sun tanjiro then wakes up in a
hospital bed after the battle against
ducky and gyutaro tanjiro had been
unconscious for two months so two months
have already passed since the final
events of demon Slayers season 2. when
tanjiro wakes up Kano is there to greet
him and she smiles and says that she's
glad that tanjiro is finally awake by
the time tanjira wakes up zenitsu is
already out on another mission although
he went reluctantly since he's not a big
fan of danger tang and uzui was of
course injured during the fight but he
is alive and well and he is being cared
for by his three hot ninja wives so you
know I'm sure he'll be fine as for
inosuke his condition was extremely
serious for a time because poison got
deep inside his body but he managed to
recover because he has an abnormally
strong tolerance for Poison Poison just
doesn't work on him as it does on a
normal person although neither does
medicine so it's a bit of a trade-off
that said inosuke did manage to fully
recover and he woke up about a week
before tanjiro he is now already up and
running and jumping and clinging to the
ceiling and all the usual inosuke stuff
a week after this tanjiro recovers
enough to get back on his feet meanwhile
inosuke is also sent out on a mission
just like zenitsu was while undergoing
some extremely painful Physical Therapy
tanjiro asks whether a new Katana was
delivered for him while he was asleep
because as we know his sword was damaged
during the fight against upper Moon 6.
unfortunately for tanjiro his swordsmith
haganezuka got mad that tanjiro damaged
his sword again and he refused to send a
new one instead he sent a bunch of angry
letters cursing tanjiro for his
mistreatment of swords and so finding
himself without a working Katana tanjiro
has to visit the swordsmith village in
order to procure a new sword however the
swordsmith village is not an ordinary
Village its location is a tightly
guarded secret hardly anyone knows where
the village is even within the Demon
Slayer core when tanjiro makes the
journey to the Village he is escorted
there by masked kakushi or attendance he
is blindfolded so that he can't see
where he is going his ears are plugged
so that he can't hear his surroundings
and even his nose is plugged because he
has a sensitive nose that could possibly
give him hints about where they're going
he is then carried on the back of a
kakushi but only part of the way an
entire relay team of kakushi divide up
the route to the swordsmith village and
only the final kakushi actually knows
where the village is the kakushi are
Guided by crows but both the crows and
the kakushi are often changed and even
the roots by which the villages reached
are also changed regularly the Demon
Slayer core goes through all this
trouble to keep the swordsmith village
hidden because it is such an important
component of their overall organization
and so they must prevent muzon and the
demons from finding it when tanjiro
finally arrives at the Village he learns
that both the love hashira mitsuri
khandroji and the Mist hashira muichiro
tokito are also there as is genya
shinazugawa the younger brother of the
wind hashira sanami since tanjiro still
hasn't fully recovered he hopes that he
can recoup his strength inside the
village and enjoy the hot springs while
waiting for his new Katana to be
completed but unfortunately for tanjiro
and all the demon Slayers and
swordsmiths within the swordsmith
village remember that information that
gyoko said he had for muzon yeah it was
actually the secret location of the
swordsmith village this means that two
upper moons gyoko and huntengu are about
to invade the swordsmith village so that
is what happened during the time skip
between the end of the Entertainment
District Arc and the big beginning of
the swordsmith village Arc and that is
the setup for the main conflict of this
season more than two months passed
between the two arcs and for most of the
time tanjiro was unconscious inosuke and
zenitsu are currently away on other
missions so they will not be featured in
this Arc but tanjiro and nezuko are here
as are mitsuri muichiro genya and two of
the six upper moons this Arc is going to
be epic and tragic and so much more so
do not miss it and don't forget to
subscribe to anime outpro so you don't
miss any of our regular Demon Slayer
content there is a lot more coming if
you're looking for something to watch
next check out our video on 101 secrets
in Demon Slayer it's a great way to test
your knowledge of Demon's air and get
caught up on all the facts as you get
into season three and of course if you
enjoyed this video leave a quick like
right now to help us with that YouTube
algorithm as always thank you guys guys
so much for watching and until next time
see ya Space Cowboys